las autoridades alemanas confirmaron
ocho muertes en Hamburgo entre ellas se
cuentan cuatro hombres y dos mujeres
otra que sobrevivió al ataque perdió su
embarazo de siete meses también figura
el tirador que abrió fuego en un centro
de Testigos de Jehová antes de quitarse
la vida
El atacante fue encontrado muerto en la
iglesia de los Testigos de Jehová
Aparentemente abriéndose apuntado el
arma era un ex miembro de los Testigos
de Jehová y abandonó voluntariamente la
comunidad hace un año y medio
Aparentemente soltero y vivió y trabajó
en Hamburgo desde 2014
la respuesta de la policía fue rápida
impidiendo que el incidente tuviera
peores consecuencias hasta el momento se
descartan las motivaciones terroristas o
políticas y no se descarta que el
atacante un ex miembro de los Testigos
de Jehová tuviera problemas mentales la
comunidad religiosa reconocida como una
de las principales religiones de
Alemania está conmocionada el canciller
Ola también se dijo estupefacto
anoche hubo un terrible incidente en mi
ciudad natal de Hamburgo varias personas
han sido Víctimas de un brutal acto de
violencia mi pensamiento está con ellas
y con sus familias
Alemania se ha visto sacudida por
tiroteos en los últimos años como el de
febrero de 2020 en el que un sospechoso
de extrema derecha mató a nueve personas
en hallow incluyendo inmigrantes turcos
en la segunda ciudad más grande de
Alemania la alerta que prohibía los
habitantes salir de sus casas se levantó
al cabo de unas horas